so I promised a demo of App Engine in
action taking load so oh the here's my
my kubernetes app it decided to load
okay so I have here a set of ten VMs
compute engine VMs and they're going to
hit that URL please you can hit the URL
don't hit that URL no no don't because
you'll you'll break the whole like from
cold we're going to see how App Engine
scales so you can hit it after I'm done
the demo if that's your thing so I'm
going to go ahead and run one make
command and I'll explain what I'm doing
instructing each one of my VMs to send a
thousand hits at that URL and to do it
concurrently at 50 apiece so a 500 QPS
query so I'm going to run that we're
gonna switch back over here someone hit
the URL someone did it that's alright
you'll still see some magic so in a
moment they're going to you see as soon
as compute engine gets the traffic and
start sending it they start bouncing and
that is App Engine spinning up instances
of my application in order to handle the
load that's coming in and basically what
will happen is it can handle each
instance can handle a certain amount of
traffic at once and then say hey a
little peg and we'll start spinning up
more instances to take it that's how
quickly we've split up instances in
order to deal with your traffic and
that's why the whole scale of 0 is
awesome right because it quickly
responds when you have traffic but then
when you have we don't have traffic it
starts going start spinning down
instances and three of you your queues
three of you for all right well now I
don't care now you can just pick in a
way all you want and you can see the
numbers go up in real-time yeah yeah
you're really doing that you're really
hitting the URL whoa all right
I've challenged people there they're
feeling feisty so that's just a quick
demo of what App Engine can do